NATE BROOLING: So, hi, guys.
My name is Nate Brooling.
I sit across the
street over in sales,
look after the
Microsoft business.
So nice to meet you.
We're here today because of a
good friend of mine, Erik Fay,
was talking to me
about this fantastic
story and this incredible woman
and team behind her as well.
So he asked, you
know, hey, would
be possible to have a chat at
Google, and I said absolutely.
Let's do this.
So I have the pleasure
of introducing
Barbara Arrowsmith-Young today.
And today's talk is going to
be about a personal journey
into the world of the
brain, shaping the mind.
Such a cool title, right?
Very exciting.
I've got three kids, so I'm
watching my kids develop over
the years, and it's just
been incredible to me.
And I cannot wait to see
what we're about to see.
So I'm going to be quick.
But before I bring her
up, a bit more about her--
she holds a bachelor in
applied science, child studies,
a masters in school psychology
from the University of Toronto.
Her work began in 1978,
and it's been recognized
as one of the first examples
of practical application
of neural plasticity,
which simply means
the ability of the brain
to change and rewire itself
over one's lifetime.
It's fantastic.
The genesis of the program
lies in Barbara's own journey
of discovery and innovation
to overcome her learning
disabilities, a description
of which appears in her book
that you guys have.
So thank you for
bringing those today.
And there will be a
signing afterwards.
And the name of the book
is titled "The Woman
Who Changed Her Brain."
Many reviewers have
written about her book.
To share one of the
quotes-- I really
like this one-- "It will open
your mind to new possibilities
and how to deal with
traffic jams in the brain."
So I know a lot of us,
especially at Google, we
have a lot of traffic
jams, sounds fitting.
Her life has been a quest
to help individuals address
learning difficulties
so they can
experience the ease
and joy of learning
as well as achieve their dreams.
This program is
in over 91 schools
across several countries,
Canada, USA, Australia, New
Zealand, Malaysia,
Thailand, and South Korea.
So I'm really excited
to have her here.
Let's give her a warm welcome.
Thank you.
Thank
[APPLAUSE]
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG:
And I'm sorry, guys,
one more thing before we start.
Please silence your phones.
Thank you.
Well, I want to thank Erik Fay
for making the introduction
and thank you Nate for
providing me the opportunity
to speak about what I'm
most passionate about,
which is our human
brain is incredible
complexity and the
possibility for change.
It's sort of what
I'm probably most
passionate about in the world.
And my life and
my work has really
been an exploration of the
territory of the human brain,
how it makes us
uniquely who we are.
Because when we think
about our brain,
it filters our
perceptions of ourselves
and our understanding
of ourselves,
our understanding
of other people,
our understanding of the
world, and our understanding
of our relationship to that.
So really, really
critical in terms
of mediating our experience.
And to me, what's really
promising is not only
does our brain shape
who we are, but now
we know with this concept
of neuroplasticity
that we can actually
shape our brain
if we can understand how we
can harness those principles.
And also I think what's
really interesting,
we often hear the
comment about he
or she is just not good at that.
And we often attribute not
being good at something
as coming out of maybe
an emotional base.
You know, that
person is just rude
or they're not good socially.
And I would like
to encourage people
to start to look at behavior
through a cognitive lens.
I mean, behavior's
multiply determined.
It's not just cognitive.
But I think we
ignore the cognitive.
If there's any part
of our brain that
isn't fully operational
or functioning,
it will have an impact
in terms of our behavior.
And I'm going to take you a
little bit into that world
today.
So science has taught
us that, as I said,
our brain really does shape us.
And if we think about
how complex it is,
we have something on the
order of 86 billion neurons
that we're carrying
around in our head.
And to put that into
perspective, the world's
population is somewhere
between 7 and 8 billion,
so incredible complexity.
And we have several hundred
trillion connections
or superhighways in the brain,
connecting different regions
for neural transmission
and communication.
And again, to put
that into perspective,
we have more
connections in our brain
than all the stars in the Milky
Way galaxy-- so incredibly
complex.
And we can't really
escape our brain,
because we carry it
everywhere we go.
Also what I find
really fascinating
is no two brains
are exactly alike.
So if you think about
somebody that you know well
or you look at somebody
sitting next to you,
and you note that there
are physical differences
between the two of you.
You may have different eye
color or different shape
of your nose, different
shape of your ears.
There are actually
more differences
between your two brains than all
of those physical differences
combined.
So our brain really does
make us uniquely who we are.
And to me, as I said what's
really, really promising
is this concept of
neuroplasticity.
We now know that we can actually
grow new neurons in the brain,
in the hippocampus, which is
really important for memory
and for learning.
We know that we can
increase neurotransmitters.
We know that we can increase
the branches, the dendrites,
on the neurons to enhance
neural transmission.
So we can actually
change our brain.
So my story begins
with my brain.
And it's really a
story of a quest
and a hunt for a solution
to my very severe learning
disabilities that were
identified in grade 1.
So it's a very personal
story, but it's also
universal in that each
and every one of us
has a brain that
impacts our functioning.
And if we think about
having a brain that's
capable and incapable
at the same time,
that's the experience of someone
with a learning difficulty.
There are things that
we can do very easily,
and then there are other
things that with the best
will in the world they're
really incredibly challenging.
And that certainly
was my experience.
So for me growing up,
I lived in a world
that was about as intelligible
as Lewis Carroll's poem
"The Jabberwocky."
I didn't understand
it at the time
that I couldn't
process language.
It was almost like
I heard the words.
I mean, I knew what
the words were,
but I struggled
to interpret them,
to attach meaning to them.
So for me, I could understand
things very concretely.
I mean, if somebody said
it's raining outside,
which I understand it does
quite a bit here in Seattle,
I could understand that
because I could conjure up
a visual image of rain.
But as soon as it got
abstract, conceptual, it
was impossible to me.
Something as simple
as-- you know,
I couldn't understand
how my aunt could also
be my mother's sister.
I could not understand.
How could somebody
have two relationships?
In terms of numbers, I
mean, I could understand 1
because I could put
one object up here.
I could understand 4 because
I could line up four objects.
You put that 1 over
top of a 4, which
is a relationship of a part to
a whole, it meant nothing to me.
Bigger than, greater
than, less than, under,
over, anything that had
a relational connotation
was incredibly difficult
or impossible for me
to understand.
My notebooks were
filled with diagrams.
I used my right hemisphere
to try to interpret language
by making drawings to try to
connect the relationships.
Things as simple as
jokes-- I didn't understand
jokes because it
depends on irony.
So not wanting to feel left
out as a child, what I would do
is I would laugh as much
as everybody else was
laughing because I didn't
want to feel left out.
But I had no idea what
they were laughing at.
I was really vulnerable
to con artists
because how do you understand
that you're being conned?
You hear logical inconsistency
is what somebody was saying.
Well, for me, there was
no logic in my world
so there were no
logical inconsistency.
So, you know, I easily
believed what people told me.
And something as simple
as telling time-- I
couldn't read an analog clock.
In fact, I couldn't read an
analog clock until I was 26
and created my first
exercise for myself
because to interpret
time, you have
to understand the
relationship between the hour
hand and the minute
hand, and I couldn't
understand that relationship.
So any kind of abstract
ideas, concepts were hard.
I got identified in grade 1
as being rigid and stubborn.
And I really was rigid
and stubborn, but again,
not coming from an
emotional place.
It was a cognitive difficulty.
Because for me, any kind of
understanding was so hard won.
So if I came to
understand something,
I wanted to hold onto
it for dear life.
And if somebody
said, well, think
about another way
of doing something,
think about an
alternative, it felt
like I had to let go of
this that was so hard for me
to grasp to integrate
something else.
And I just felt my whole
world would fall apart.
So maybe in your lives
you know somebody
that's really
rigid and stubborn,
and it might be because they
can't compare and contrast.
They can't see alternatives or
weigh decisions or differences.
And what ended up
happening in my life
was that very fragmented and
fractured view of my world--
because nothing connected.
There was no cause and
effect in my world.
In fact, I thought there was
some puppet master up there
pulling strings
because I couldn't
understand why things happened.
It led to an incredibly
fractured and fragmented sense
of myself.
And I described
my world as living
in a fog where meaning
was just ephemeral,
and it would disappear into
a mist of just uncertainty,
and kind of joke that I
lived in amygdala hell.
I was terrified all
the time because I
didn't understand the meaning
of what was happening around me.
And if that wasn't enough,
I had another difficulty.
So I had what would be
considered multiple learning
disabilities.
So I struggled to register
the location of sensation
on the left side of my body.
So most people, if you go to
put your hand on a hot burner,
your brain is going
to tell you pain.
It's going to tell you
pain in your left hand.
Pull it up.
And I mean, it's going to be
just an automatic process.
You're not going to
stop and think about it.
Well for me, my brain
would tell me pain,
but it wouldn't register where
the pain was coming from.
So I'd leave my hand on
the hot burner, which
really wasn't a very good idea.
So I learned, probably
around age three or four,
that I had to watch the
left side of my body
because it would do things.
It was almost like
an alien being.
It would do things.
I slammed a car door on my
head once with my left hand
and shattered a tooth.
My mother was convinced
by probably about age 5
that I would not live
very long because I
was so accident-prone.
But it was a cognitive area
that just wouldn't register
the location of sensation.
And imagine me on a sports team.
I mean, I struggled
academically.
Nobody wanted me on their
sports team in school,
and I understood why.
Like, I truly wasn't an
asset because I was so clumsy
and ended up being bruised and
banged and kind of battered.
And then imagine
me driving a car.
If I didn't know where
the left side of my body
was, once I started
to drive a car,
I didn't know where the
left side of that car was.
So not only was my body
bruised and banged--
it was actually my parents'
car, because when I first
started driving, their car was
bruised and banged and dented
on the left side by extension.
And then there was another
area that wasn't working,
the area that allows
you to represent
three dimensional
space inside your head.
I couldn't do that.
So I couldn't create
maps inside my head.
Geography, geometry
any activity-- chess,
checkers-- that involved
a spatial component was
really, really hard for me.
And again, things that
we take for granted
like crossing the street was
really terrifying because when
you cross the street,
what you actually
do, kind of
automatically, is you
create a mental map of where
you are relative to that car
coming at you.
I couldn't do that,
so I had no idea where
I was relative to that car.
So my compensation
was to walk blocks out
of my way to find a stop
sign or a stop light
where I knew cars had
to stop and then would
be relatively safe crossing.
Or my other strategy was to
wait by the side of the road
until somebody else
came along to cross,
and I would follow
them, and I would
pray that they didn't have
the same difficulty that I did
and that we'd get across safely.
And I used to joke that I
would be as safe crossing
the street with my eyes
closed as with my eyes open,
which was probably pretty
accurate, because I couldn't
do that spatial representation.
And I would always get
lost because for me, there
were no maps.
I didn't even understand
that streets connected.
So I couldn't hold any kind
of spatial representation
in my head.
So any time I went
somewhere, I had to calculate
in what I called "lost time."
So I would always
give myself extra time
because I knew I would get lost
several times before I finally
found my way.
And so those were some of
the areas, the main ones,
that I struggled with.
And so for me, when I began
my schooling in the 1950s,
it was in the time
of what I call
the pre-neuroplastic paradigm.
So when I started in grade
1, the traditional belief
was, if you have
a learning problem
or there's a problem
in your brain,
nothing you can do about it.
Basically the brain you're born
with is the brain you die with.
There was no concept
of neuroplasticity.
In fact, people
believed there was
no such thing as
neuroplasticity-- most people.
So in grade 1, I overheard
my teacher tell my mother
that I had a mental
block, because this
was before the term "learning
disability" had even
been invented.
And being very concrete,
I just actually
imagined that I had
a piece of wood,
like a nice wooden cube,
lodged in my head that
made learning really
difficult. And later I
learned I didn't have a
wooden cube, but in a sense,
I had blockages.
There were parts of my brain
that weren't working properly.
But imagine, like in grade 1,
I was given a life sentence,
told that I would never
learn like other children,
that all of my
academic career would
be an incredible struggle,
and that I was really
condemned to living in that
world of disconnected elements
and confusion and fog.
And that really
was my experience
going through school.
I did eventually learn how
to read and to write and do
kind of simple numeracy.
I used my strengths.
I have a verbatim
auditory memory.
I can listen to things and just
like a little tape recorder
remember them.
And I have a photographic visual
memory, so I can look at print
and remember.
And that's what got me through.
And I had incredible
drive and determination.
So I never understood anything.
I could memorize it and then
match it up on the exam.
And I would get anywhere
from 10% on an exam to 100%,
depending if I made
the right match.
The 10%, you know, I
made a really bad match
because I didn't
really understand
what was being asked.
The 100%, I made a better
match, probably really
didn't understand
what was going on,
but I just was lucky
to make a better match.
But what my teachers
would conclude,
if I could get 100% at
one point and I got 10%,
I must not have worked
very hard for that 10%.
And I worked as hard for the
10% as I did for the 100%.
So certainly, it was a
confusing picture for teachers.
So I was very, very lucky.
My father was a scientist
and an inventor,
had something on the
order of 40 patents.
He conditioned electricity.
And I kind of caught that
creative passion from him.
I really didn't understand
anything that he was doing,
but I felt that
desire to create.
And he told me as
I was growing up,
he said, if there's a
problem in your life,
and there's no solution
out there in the world,
he said, it's your
responsibility
to go out and find a solution
to the problem, kind of probably
like what all of you do here.
You find solutions to problems.
And he also said
something really wise
that I've taken with
me through my life.
He said, don't be limited
by conventional wisdom.
He said, if the rest
of the world tells you
you can't do this,
he said, ignore them.
Don't listen.
Go out and do it.
So I set on a quest
to try to find
a solution to my difficulties.
And for me, the solution came--
two brilliant researchers.
The first one, Alexander Luria,
a Russian neuropsychologist
doing a lot of work in Russia
after World War II, where
there were a lot of
Russian soldiers with very
localized head wounds.
And what he would do was
investigate, clinically,
by giving them tests to try
to understand if there's
damage to this part of the
brain, what can the person no
longer do?
Therefore by inference, what
does that part of the brain do?
And he's really one of
the seminal thinkers
in neuropsychology
and neuroscience
that started to map the
brain many, many years ago.
So he helped with
identification of the function
of different parts of the brain.
And I came across a
book that he had written
called "The Man with
the Shattered World,"
and it was a story of
a Russian soldier who,
in 1943 in the
battle of Smolensk,
had a shrapnel wound
to a part of his brain
in the left hemisphere,
very localized wound.
And as I read this
man's story, I thought,
this man is living my life
several decades earlier
and halfway around
the world in Russia.
He was using the same
language in his journal,
talking about living
in a fog where
meaning was ephemeral
and would disappear
that I was using
in my journal, you
know, decades later
and in Canada.
So I had an epiphany
at that point
because I knew I had
terrible problems,
but I had no idea what the
source of the problems were.
And to solve a
problem, you kind of
have to get an idea of what
the nature of the problem is.
So now into the nature.
I knew it was part of my brain
that wasn't working properly.
So that was great.
But then what do
I do about that?
The next piece of
the puzzle came
in the work of Mark Rosenzweig.
And he was in Berkeley
working with rats
because they're a lot easier
to work with the people.
And what he was
doing was putting
rats in a really
enriched environment,
with a lot of
stimulation, then he
would compare them
to rats in a normal
or an unenriched environment.
And he would put them in little
rat intelligence tests, which
is running a maze, and
he found those rats
that had had the
enriched experience were
able to learn the maze much more
efficiently and effectively.
And then because they were
rats, he cut their heads open
and looked at their brains.
And what he found was the brains
had changed physiologically
for those rats that
had the enrichment.
There were more
neurotransmitters.
There were more-- you can see
you the slide of the neuron,
more dendrite, so more
synaptic connections
if there are more dendritic
branches, more glial
cells, enlarged capillaries,
so more blood flowing
to the regions.
I think there are something like
12 physiological variables that
had changed with
the enrichment that
led to-- he inferred--
the improved
performance on the mazes.
So I had to infer, even
though nobody was looking
at it at that time, or
believe, that if rats
had neuroplasticity, humans like
we must have neuroplasticity,
and I kind of thought
that we probably had
more neuroplasticity than rats.
So I thought if, you know,
I can take Lurie's work
and understand the nature of
what that part of the brain
is supposed to do,
like what's its job
and what's its
function, maybe I could
find an activity or
a task that would
stimulate it to make it work.
And I figured, it might not
work, because the rest of world
was saying it
couldn't, but what did
I have to lose other than time?
And I was 25, 26.
I couldn't tell
time, so I figured,
what does it really matter?
Let me try it.
So at the age of 26, I set
out with the first exercise,
and what did I use?
I used clocks-- not that
I wanted to get better
at telling time,
but the concept is,
you need to force the brain
to do what it's designed to do
but what is really
difficult. And I
couldn't do the
relational piece, so used
the clocks to force
processing relationships.
And I got really fast at reading
a two-handed clock really
accurate.
I mean, I was pretty
abysmal at the beginning,
and that was great.
So now I could tell
time, but I didn't
feel any cognitive change.
And to drive
neuroplastic change,
you have to increase
novelty and complexity.
So what I did is I kept adding
more hands, more relationships.
And now we have a
10-handed clock,
which anybody can benefit.
The only two people that
have ever looked at it
and interpreted it, one
had discovered quasars,
radio-emitting galaxies.
He was an astronomer.
And the other was a
physicist from Harvard.
So I knew I was on to something
with this really advanced
level.
And in fact, right
now I'm talking
to a university in
Spain, and they're
looking at putting
that reasoning exercise
into their universities,
so every student
will go into a cognitive lab
and work on that exercise four
hours a week.
And over a 10-month
span, we'll supercharge
that cognitive function in
terms of being able to reason.
And it's that ability to process
relationships simultaneously.
It's insight, like
all this information,
disparate information, comes
together, and you say, aha.
That's what that means.
That's what this function is.
And also what I
found interesting
is I've worked with a
number of psychiatrists.
My head school's in Toronto,
and as Nate mentioned,
there are schools
all around the world
that implement this program.
And if somebody
has this problem,
they can't benefit
from insight therapy.
Because insight
therapy means that you
have to make cause and effect.
You have to see relationships
between your behavior
and emotions and other
people's actions.
And as students work
on this exercise,
if they're in a therapeutic
process, what the psychiatrist
or psychologist always
reports is at the level-- it's
about the four relationship
level of the exercise
they start to benefit
from insight therapy.
So really very profound
capacity, not that's
just going to affect
the person in school
but in their whole life.
And I've had some
students that have
come to me that have
been misdiagnosed
as having Asperger's, which
is a high functioning autism,
because they have a severe
difficulty in this function.
And as we address this function,
it's very clear that they
don't have Asperger's.
It was just they couldn't
connect meaning to situations.
So they walked around totally
disengaged and not able
to relate to the world.
So pretty important area.
And as I worked on this
and saw the change,
for me, what happened
was I could now
start to live in what
I call real time.
Whereas before, I lived
in what I called lag time.
Because if I listened
to a conversation,
I would memorize it.
I would have that little
tape recorder going,
and I would walk away and maybe
go over and over and over it
for two, three hours
to try to understand
what were those people saying.
And in some cases, I could,
and in some cases I couldn't.
But even if I could,
it was three hours
after the conversation,
so I couldn't be
part of that human discourse.
Now I could listen to somebody.
I could understand
as they were talking.
I could actually make a
comment and interject,
understand what
they said back to me
I was actually part
of human discourse,
and it was very, very profound.
I could also now
grasp math concepts.
I could understand fractions.
I went back and taught myself
all of elementary, high school,
and college mathematics.
And now I could understand
it from first principles
rather than just
memorizing formulas
and plugging in numbers.
I was no longer
rigid because I could
contrast and compare and weigh
decisions and see alternatives.
I could understand jokes.
I could tell time.
And I was no longer
vulnerable to con artists.
So all of that changed as
a result of one cognitive
exercise.
So then I thought, can
I create an exercise
to address the two other
problems that I talked about?
The first one, the
somatosensory cortex,
which you have two strips on
either side of your brain,
the somatosensory
cortex here controls
registering and location of
sensation on your left side,
and then this one
controls the right side.
So I knew there to
create an exercise,
I had to do something
with my eyes closed
because my compensation was
with my eyes watching what
that side of my body was doing
and really regulate movement
through vision not
through sensory feedback.
So I created a whole complex
exercise of doing movements
with that side of
my body with my eyes
closed and overcame
that problem.
I can now register sensation
on the left side of my body,
the location of sensation.
I don't bump into things.
I don't trip over my
feet, all of that,
because I didn't know-- if
I went to walk out a door,
I'd just as likely hit
the door frame as go
through the middle of the
door because I didn't know
where the side of my body was.
So address that.
Also, if I picked up
something in my left hand,
the first row in the audience
might end up wearing it,
because I couldn't
regulate movement.
So I would over move or
under move or drop things.
I can do all that now.
And to me what's powerful
if we can understand
this concept of neuroplasticity
is we're not teaching skills.
We're not teaching content.
We're not teaching the person
how to do or learn an activity.
We're changing the
brain's capacity
to then learn, to learn
content, to learn strategies,
to learn information.
And given that we carry our
brain with us everywhere,
it's incredibly powerful
to go under the content,
into the brain, and
stimulate that function.
And then the other
area, in the parietal,
this is a spatial area.
And again, I knew to
create an exercise there
that I had to do something
with a spatial component
and do it over and over again.
So I created an exercise
and saw the change.
And now I think in
the last three years
I've gone around the world a few
times talking about this work,
and I don't get lost.
I can actually read maps.
And I can navigate.
I can actually go to IKEA and
buy one of those bookcases
or cupboards and go from a
two dimensional representation
and build a three
dimensional representation,
which before I couldn't.
I would put the
back of the bookcase
on upside down and backwards
because you can't translate
two dimensional representation
into three dimensional space.
I can do that now.
And for me, those words
"some assembly required"
before would strike
terror into my heart.
I mean now, I know I
can assemble things.
And interestingly, some of
these are genetic, inherited.
My mother and I both
had severe difficulty.
And these things
work on a continuum.
You can be exceptionally
strong in an area.
You can have
average functioning.
You can have a mild
problem, moderate problem,
severe problem, so
anywhere on the continuum.
My mother and I were at
the severe end of this.
And as a child, getting into
the car with my mother--
I mean, she had a good attitude.
She said it's going to be an
adventure because neither of us
had any maps in our head.
So we kind of knew
where we were starting.
We knew sort of where
we wanted to end up,
but it was like a
black hole in between.
And she said, we'll always get
there, which we always did.
And we never got there
the same way twice.
But, you know, it
was an adventure.
But as I got older and
kind of understood more
about these cognitive
functions, I asked her,
did this ever have an impact
other than it took you
longer to get anywhere?
And so she shared with me
when she'd gone to university,
she'd wanted to be a chemist,
but in her first year
I was encouraged
to drop chemistry
and she went into
home economics.
She couldn't construct
those molecules,
like that spatial
representation inside your head.
It was just impossible for her.
And I really struggled
also with organic chemistry
because of this
difficulty in university.
Interestingly again, as
they work on a continuum,
I have four brothers.
And my oldest brother
has this at a mild level,
not enough to interfere
with him becoming
a chemist, which he did, at
the University of Toronto.
But he became a physical
chemist because it still
was hard for him to
construct those molecules.
So what I've
learned in this work
is that there's no
free ride, in a sense.
If there's a cognitive
area of difficulty,
it will have some impact.
It just depends on what it is,
the degree that it's there,
and what you're
doing in your life
in terms of whether
it limits you.
So in the work
that I've created,
I currently can identify
19 cognitive functions.
And if people are interested,
on our website down here
at the bottom, there's
a cognitive profile
questionnaire.
I think there's about
250 questions on it.
You can go in and
answer these questions.
It's all confidential.
And at the end, based
on your responses,
it'll give you a profile
of where, by your answers,
suggesting that there
might be some difficulties.
And then you go on the website
and read more information,
if somebody is interested.
So currently we have programs
for 18 cognitive functions.
And I'm very clear that
this isn't everything
that can go wrong with learning,
but it's a really broad range
from the person that struggles
with nonverbal interpretation
of situations.
Face blindness I
have a program for,
a person that can't
recognize landmarks
so can't navigate because
they don't remember
the look of a place;
spatial, the person that gets
lost because they can't
hold maps or three
dimensional representation;
auditory memory, the person
that just can't
hold information;
numeracy, the person that
doesn't understand number--
so a broad range of
different cognitive deficits.
And for me, you know, if
you're working on an area,
you first need to identify
where the problem is.
And if anybody
hears somebody say,
this one program is
going to fix everything,
I would say run as quickly as
you can in the other direction.
Because in terms of the brain,
there's no one size fits all.
We have an incredibly
complex organ here,
and I believe for something
to work effectively,
it has to be differentiated,
targeted stimulation
to that function.
And for example, if we
think about reading,
this is blood flow study
looking at all the brain
areas that come together
when somebody is reading.
So there is no reading
area in the brain.
The brain works in what
Luria called a functional
system, what we now call
a neural network, where
multiple areas come together,
each one having its own task.
So there's eye tracking.
There's phonemic awareness.
There's sound symbol
correspondence
to hear the speech sounds.
There's visual memory to
hold the speech pattern, eye
tracking to learn
kind of a motor plan
for the eye for reading.
All of these are critical.
So if a child or an individual's
struggling with reading,
it might be any
combination of these.
The individuals we work with
may have different components.
The individuals we see that
really are probably never going
to get past a grade 2 or
3 level reading, unless we
do this cognitive work, have
all of these areas impacted.
So there's no
piece that they can
use to compensate for
their difficulties
because every single one related
to reading is problematic.
So if you want to
see where you are
in one of these
cognitive functions,
and you can keep
it confidential,
I think probably
everybody in the room
here has seen a cat at some
point in their existence.
So this is an area in
the right hemisphere
that holds the look of things.
So if you want to
just close your eyes--
you don't have to
do it-- and see.
Can you actually see
in your mind's eye
or call up on the screen an
image or a picture of a cat, so
whoever wants to try it.
And then if you want to open
up your eyes and kind of
see how you did.
So some people are going to
see like a really, vivid, clear
image of the cat.
Some people it
would be less clear.
And some individuals
are just going
to see the back
of their eyelids.
And I often call this the
refrigerator dysfunction.
This is where the
person just doesn't hold
the visual details of objects.
So they open the fridge
door, and they say, you know,
where's the mustard?
Where's the ketchup?
I think you like
ketchup better here.
We like mustard more in Canada.
[CHUCKLING]
Because you don't hold
the picture of what
you're looking for, or
you don't like shopping--
if somebody has trouble here--
because you walk by what you're
looking for multiple
times before you just
recognize, OK, yeah, that the
Cheerios or whatever it is.
You miss details.
This will be the person
that their wife maybe
goes and gets a
make over and they
don't notice that
something is different,
because they're not holding
the visual look of what
was there before and comparing
it to what's there now.
If someone's strong here,
they'll navigate by landmarks.
They'll go someplace once
and they'll remember vividly
what it looks like and
where they have to turn
or they're really good
with visual imagery.
I worked with a student
who was studying
to be an illustrator in Canada,
and she had this difficulty--
not massively but enough that
when she would draw a cat,
she'd leave off the whiskers.
Or when she'd draw a coat,
she'd leave off the buttons.
And that was kind of
a problem if you're
going to be an
Illustrator because you
need to get the details down.
So actually she was
one of the first people
I created this exercise
for, and we worked on it.
She improved this function.
And now she's won awards in
Canada for her illustrations.
So she doesn't miss
details anymore.
One person I worked
with shared with me
that she really
hated to meditate.
She had this difficulty.
And I mean, she could
do breathing meditation,
but she couldn't do
visual imagery meditation.
So someone would tell
her to close her eyes
and go to her happy place, well,
she just saw a black screen.
So it definitely
doesn't necessarily
impact the person in school,
per se, in academic learning
but definitely in life.
If people know
Oliver Sacks's book,
"The Man Who Mistook
His Wife for a Hat."
That's this cognitive function.
I have worked with some people
that have had traumatic brain
injury.
And one of the students
I work with here
had massive right
hemisphere damage.
He'd been hit by a
truck when he was 12,
and I saw him when he
was in his early 30s.
And the first day he
came into my school,
he tried to exit
through a filing cabinet
because it was rectangular.
It had a handle.
To him, it looked like a door.
We worked on this.
And what was so amazing,
not only could he
eventually recognize
objects and landmarks,
but he developed a
visual sense of humor
because the whole visual
world became alive for him,
and he could see irony.
This area is also related
to face blindness and face
recognition.
So somebody that has
a difficulty here,
if they see somebody in context,
so they see their neighbor
on the porch in the
front house, they'll
know who that person is.
Five minutes later,
they'll see that person
in the grocery store,
no idea who they are.
So I have a program
that addresses that.
And these people often get
labeled as rude or standoffish,
and that isn't the case.
They just don't
recognize the person.
A good friend of mine
had this difficulty,
and we worked on it.
And she was a reporter
at the "Toronto
Star," which is the second
largest newspaper in Toronto.
And for 20 years, she rode
the elevator up and down
up and down.
She had no idea
every day that she
went into that
elevator-- did she
know anybody on that elevator?
So she said she had two
options-- one to just assume
she knew nobody.
And if she offended
somebody, so be it,
or pretend she knew everybody.
And if she got labeled
as being overly friendly,
so that was the
option she chose.
But at one point she got
accused of being prejudicial.
A friend said to her,
you know, oh, Linda, you
think all brown
people look alike.
And Linda said to her actually,
it's much worse than that.
All people look alike.
But because she didn't
recognize people and make
that discrimination, somebody
interpreted her behavior
as being prejudiced,
which was not accurate.
So that's this function.
This is the same
part of the brain
but now in the left hemisphere.
So one is holding the
look of the thing, which
is in your right hemisphere.
This is holding
the symbol pattern.
So, again, if you want
to just think of the word
"cat," so the three letters,
and if you want to try it,
you can close your eyes.
And can you conjure
up those three letters
on the blackboard?
And again, some people
see it really crisply.
Some people it will
be kind of fuzzy.
And a lot of the students
that we work with
don't see anything.
They can't hold the
visual look of a word.
Some researchers call this
the brain's letter box
or visual word formary.
I call it symbol recognition.
But it's critical for
spelling, for word recognition,
even learning visual
symbol templates like math
formulas, chemical equations.
We know that you can
just learn them visually.
If somebody has this
difficulty, they don't.
And I'll just give you an
example of the exercise
that we use for this area.
So for every single one
of the 19 functions,
we have very different exercises
because we're targeting
very different functions.
And this language that
the student is looking at
is Amharic from Ethiopia.
And often people
say, well, you know,
Nick is struggling
with reading English.
Why are you giving him Amharic?
The concept is
that we don't want
the child or the individual to
compensate for the difficulty.
So if we used English letters,
they could put sound to.
They could put meaning to it.
If we use Amharic or Burmese
or Sinhalese or Telugu,
they can't put sound to it.
They can't put meaning
to it because they
don't know this language.
So the idea of any
of the exercises,
we're trying to go in and target
that differentiated stimulation
right to the area, removing any
possibility of compensation.
Now you can never fully
remove compensation
because the brain
doesn't work that way.
So the student goes
through a whole process.
There's thousands of levels
in each of the exercises.
And by the end of
this exercise, they're
holding eight Chinese
characters in their mind's eye.
And after that, English
actually looks pretty easy.
But again, it's not that
we're teaching a skill.
We're changing the
brain's capacity
to hold simple patterns.
So what you see
changes with this
is word recognition,
spelling, visual matching,
visual tracking, anything
related to learning
visual symbol patterns.
And just really quickly,
if anybody is interested,
we have a number
of outcome studies
on our website, which
is arrowsmithschool.org.
So we've had studies done
in different schools,
different researchers,
different research designs,
all looking at
outcomes, so looking
at outcomes on
academic measures,
looking at outcomes in
schools with rate of learning,
looking at outcomes
on cognitive measures.
They're all summarized
on the website,
so I'm not going to
spend a lot of time
on those because
you can look at it.
But this was a study
done at the University
of Calgary, looking
at academic changes.
The one I really like-- this
was done in the Toronto Catholic
District School Board,
obviously in Toronto.
And it is a publicly
funded board.
We know that students
with learning difficulties
aren't learning a
year for a year.
So these students were learning
about 2/3 of a year per year
because they fall further and
further behind because they're
struggling with
their difficulties.
We took this group of students.
I think there were 60 students,
and we put them half a day
doing cognitive exercises.
So they're actually
getting less curriculum
than they were getting the
previous several years where
they were learning 2/3
of a year per year.
So now we're reducing their
curriculum exposure by half.
And what we found a year
after the intervention,
they were doubling and
tripling their rate
of learning having
had less academics
because we changed the
brain's capacity to learn.
I mean, again, I keep saying
this over and over again.
But this is the
power of the brain.
You change the opacity
of it to learn,
the learning just starts
to go forward even
when it had less exposure.
These students could have
sat in those English classes
and those math classes for
year after year after year,
and they were still going
to be learning at 2/3
of a year per year.
It needed the cognitive
intervention to shift that.
And then we've looked
at cognitive measures.
Again, this was
another study done
at the University of Calgary
in the BrainGain Lab,
seeing changes on memory,
auditory processing,
fluid reasoning as a result
of the students working
on these cognitive exercises.
And to me, what's most exciting
is the research studies
that we started the last
year, year and a half,
two years ago, imaging research.
Because my hypothesis all
the way through this work
has been it's the
brain that's changing.
It made sense.
That was the inference I made
when I started this work,
but I didn't have access to this
kind of research to do imaging.
It's actually quite expensive.
So we have a researcher at the
University of British Columbia
just north of here in
Vancouver, Dr. Laura Boyd
and at the University of
Southern Illinois, Dr. Greg
Rose.
And we're doing similar
studies looking at students
with learning difficulties
and the intervention.
And we're seeing
very similar results,
which hopefully
within the next year
will be published in
peer reviewed journals.
So we had to adapt the reasoning
exercise for the scanner,
because if you've ever been
an fMRI, you can barely move.
You have to lie.
But what I wanted
the researcher to do
was scan the students
prior to intervention
and scan them three months in.
Because what we see
with students all around
the world in this program
is at about the two
to three-month mark, they start
to experience cognitive change.
They start to be able to do
things they couldn't do before.
And parents start
to notice that.
Teachers start to notice that.
People around them
start to notice that.
So I wanted to
see, was something
actually happening in the
brain at the three month mark?
So we can see a time point zero,
with the reasoning exercise,
the brain is processing
quite inefficiently.
It's taking up a lot of real
estate to do that activity.
And again, this is
very preliminary data,
and we've got more data.
We've got, I think, 10-month
data now that's being analyzed.
But what we were seeing
at three months, much more
efficient processing,
less real estate taken up
to do that reasoning activity
as a result of the intervention.
And another thing
that we're finding
in this preliminary data is
if we look at the first-- you
take the time activity at
one, time activity at two,
subtract the two,
and see, is there
something different
between the two time
points that's consistent?
And what we're seeing is
the insula is changing.
It's that little area in
the bottom slide that's
kind of lit up on
the left hand side
all the way across in all the
students doing the reasoning
exercise.
And to me, it makes
sense, because one
of the jobs of the insula is
to attach meaning to things.
It's to process information
and make sense out
of it, which is what
I had difficulty with
and what that exercise
shifted for me.
And then what is
also really positive
is we're seeing a change
in the prefrontal cortex,
the front parts of the brain.
So here you can see
a time point zero.
There's very little
prefrontal cortex activation.
And here at three
months, significant--
this is the most important
part of our brain.
This is the part
that you probably
use every day in your job.
This is thinking, problem
solving, strategizing.
It's analyzing a situation.
You've got a problem in front of
you to solve, and what happens
is this is the part
of the brain that
activates first to start to
call in resources of how am I
going to solve that problem?
What am I going to do?
And then as you're trying
to solve the problem,
this is the area that allows
you to reflect on the results.
So, you know, this isn't working
here, what do I have to do?
How do I have to modify it?
It's that constant feedback loop
as you're solving a problem.
We know students with
learning difficulties struggle
with that, and that's what we're
seeing at the zero time point
is they're not using
that part of the brain
very efficiently or effectively.
At time point three, they're
starting to use that.
And that's what we
see behaviorally.
We see these students become
better problem solvers,
better executive functioning.
So to me, it's really exciting
that we're seeing the behavior,
and now we're actually seeing
the most important part
of the brain shifting.
We're also doing another study
at UBC with this researcher.
And this is working with
people traumatic brain injury.
And we're just finishing nine
months of data collection.
These are individuals that
were in car accidents, pretty
significant trauma.
I mean, a lot of them
had been in comas.
We got them several years
after the traumatic event,
which means any spontaneous
remission would happen.
I mean, my work is
designed for people
with learning difficulties,
but over the years,
we had people come in--
because the brain is
the brain-- with traumatic
injury and we saw the results.
So we thought, let's study this.
You can't open the newspaper
now without reading
about concussion injuries,
even blast injuries, people
coming back from the
various war situations.
And what we're
finding, the research
actually was just presented
last week in the Netherlands.
The researchers
are really excited.
They've got the
three-month data analyzed.
They're just starting to
analyze the six-month data.
The end of March will
be the nine month data.
So by July, we should
have publications.
The research has
just been accepted
in "The Journal for the
Frontiers of Neuroscience."
But we're seeing
changes in connectivity,
the same similar
kinds of changes
that we're seeing
in the students
with learning difficulties,
so change in connectivity
in the brain.
Some change in myelin which
is, again, that connectivity,
and we're seeing change in
what's called fluid cognition.
So the first kind
of striped section
are the people with a
traumatic brain injury,
prior to intervention.
The blue are just normal
students or individuals
without traumatic brain injury.
And the red, in the
middle, is where
they are three months after.
So you can see they're starting,
and it's a significant change
starting to move up to normal.
And why is fluid
cognition important?
This is that thinking,
problem solving,
being able to step
into a situation,
figure it out, and
operate in that situation
critical for life.
And we're seeing changes
in other measures.
So really I'm very
excited because you
know the work can now
be a benefit for people
not just with
learning difficulties
but with people with
traumatic injury.
And again, what are some of
the areas like auditory memory?
This is the person that
goes to the grocery store,
like you send them out--
can you buy me three things?
You don't write it down.
You just tell them.
They come back with only one
thing because they can't hold
the information, or the
child that comes home
and knows they have
homework but kind
of no idea exactly what that
homework is because they
can't hold the information.
And often they get
labeled as being
irresponsible because they don't
do what you ask them to do.
And truly, if they
have a difficulty here,
they're not irresponsible.
They just can't hold
the information.
I know people that have Post-it
notes all up around their house
because they have this problem.
If they don't have their
notes or their to-do lists,
they aren't going to remember
what they have to do.
Then number sense or
quantity blindness,
I've worked with
a lot of people,
but one that kind of stands out
was a psychiatrist in Toronto.
And she would
double book clients
because she kind of had
no idea of like really
what was 60 minutes.
It wasn't that she wanted
to make more money by having
two clients in the
same time period,
but she just
struggled with that.
She struggled with
balancing her checkbook.
I worked with an opera singer
that couldn't do time signature
in music because of this area.
We addressed the
cognitive function.
She was able to do her
musical theory exam.
You know, the individual that
struggles with motor planning,
this was a student that
couldn't put their thoughts down
on paper.
So we've probably
met people like this.
They tell you a story.
It can be really elaborate.
You put a pen in their
hand, nothing much
goes down on paper.
It's because they've
got the thoughts
and the ideational content.
There's nothing wrong
with their thoughts.
It's just the
motor system that's
translating the thoughts
into a motor plan for writing
isn't working properly.
This was the same student 11
months later, same 10 minutes,
went on for three pages.
We didn't teach him
how to hand write.
We changed his brain's ability
to get his thoughts down
on paper.
Just really quickly,
another area, this
is in the right hemisphere.
This is what one researcher
calls cognitive Goldilocks.
We've all met people
with this difficulty.
It's where they look at
a situation, nonverbal,
a social situation.
They kind of take one clue
or cue from that situation.
They don't look at
everything going on.
They make an
interpretation, which
isn't the full interpretation,
and then they act on that.
So they get into
trouble socially.
They're considered sort
of inept or awkward
because they haven't
read all the information
and interpreted it correctly.
A good negotiator has
to be really strong here
because they have to
walk into a negotiation,
and they have to do that
minute by minute reading
of what effect am I getting?
Am I getting the situation
to move in the direction I
want it to move?
An example is if we
look at this picture,
I gave it to a
12-year-old girl who
had really significant
social problems.
Nobody in her neighborhood
would play with her.
In fact, everybody said
she lies all the time.
I asked her what was
happening in this picture,
and she told me they
were playing badminton.
And I asked her why
she thought that,
and it's sort of hard
to see in this picture,
but this woman has
netting on her hat.
And this is severe
premature closure.
She looked at the netting.
It triggered an association--
badminton, net, badminton.
They're playing badminton.
She didn't look at all the
rest of the information.
So in her non-verbal
world, her social world,
it wasn't she was lying.
She just misinterpreted
things all the time.
And there are lots of examples.
Another girl looked at this.
She was 18.
And she told me they were
at city hall in Toronto.
And I'd been to City
Hall many times,
and I didn't really think
it looked quite like that.
And she pointed to the
rope in the foreground.
And she'd been to City
Hall the week before,
and there was an area
cordoned off with a rope.
So again, that
premature closure.
She looked at one
element, interpreted it,
and ran with that
interpretation.
In both cases, we addressed
this cognitive function.
The 12-year-old is now 30.
She's successful in the world.
She can read nonverbal
interpretation
and so is the other individual.
So again, we're
not teaching them
skills or rules, because there
is no rule book for life.
You've got to go into
all these situations
and be able to handle the
situations in real time,
and that's what we're giving
the brain's ability to do.
I'm just going to kind
of cover this and then
open for questions.
I work with a lot of adults
in my school in Toronto
and a number of the schools.
Here there's a school in
Redmond, Eaton Arrowsmith
Academy, that works
with adults as well.
And I see a lot of
adults that have
what I call a
cognitive mismatch.
This is where the
demands of their job
aren't quite aligned with
their cognitive profile.
So if we think about
that auditory memory,
I worked with a pilot,
an airline pilot, once.
And he couldn't hold
all of the instructions
from the air traffic controller.
And I found that a
little worrisome.
His strategy was to have the
air traffic controller repeat
the instructions over
and over, but I thought,
like, what if you're flying
into Chicago O'Hare or Atlanta
that are really busy airports?
And that air traffic
controller really
doesn't have time to
repeat those instructions,
and he can't remember them.
So my joke was, if
I was ever flying,
I wanted to know what airspace
he was flying in so I didn't
fly in the same airspace.
But the better
strategy was address
the problem, which we did.
And now he can listen to the
information once and hold it.
If we think about that
object recognition, what
I call the refrigerator
dysfunction,
I worked with the
pathologist, or he
was in doing his
residency in pathology,
at a teaching
hospital in the US.
He had that difficulty.
And he didn't really know
he had that difficulty.
He was examining breast tissue.
It was somebody that had
had cancer, breast cancer,
and she'd gone through
traditional treatments.
So she'd gone through
chemotherapy and radiation,
and now it was to see,
was she in remission?
And he knew how important this
was, so he was really careful.
He was diligent.
He was looking at that slide.
And he was just
about to sign off
that the person was
in remission when
his supervisor came
and said, didn't you
see these cells up here?
This is cancer.
And it's not that
he hadn't seen them.
He hadn't recognized them
because he hadn't held the look
to match it up to that.
So he knew he was
in serious trouble.
He exited out of his
residency program.
We worked on that
cognitive function.
He now will never
make that mistake.
But I think there are a lot
of what we call human error.
And some of it can be explained
by these cognitive mismatches.
That kinesthetic,
that problem I had,
where you don't interpret
sensation or register sensation
on your left side
of your body, I've
had some students that
think it's a great idea
to get a motorcycle and they
can't register sensation
and don't kind of regulate
their body movement
and have a number of
accidents on that motorcycle
because it plays
into that difficulty.
So, I mean, what have I learned?
Every part of the
brain is critical.
If anybody says you only use
10% of your brain, tell them,
well, I'm not going to swear.
Tell them that
they're not accurate
because over the
course of a day,
you use every part
of your brain.
And if there's something
that's not working in the way
that it's designed to work,
it will have some impact.
Most of us can compensate.
Or we just avoid those
things that are hard for us.
Obviously, a lot of
the students that I
work with, I mean from
age 6-- the oldest
person I've worked
with is 81-- these
are things where they pile up.
They have multiple areas that
are coming together that cause
difficulty and where they cannot
really effectively compensate.
My vision is to get this
work-- starting in grade 1,
every child coming to
school learns curriculum,
which is what we all do.
But what do we learn with?
We learn with out brain.
So part of their day is
devoted to cognitive exercises,
to stimulate function.
And what would that do?
It would mean the students
now that by grade 3 or 4
would get identified,
will never get identified.
Because by grade 3 or 4, these
problems will be addressed.
It will become a normal
part of curriculum,
so there'll be no stigma.
Because there's
tremendous stigma still
attached to having a
learning difficulty.
Students with unevenness
in their profile-- I
worked with a student.
His mechanical reasoning
was at the 50th percentile,
which is average.
He wanted to be an architect.
You need to be at
the 90th percentile.
I created my mechanical
reasoning exercise for him,
got him to the 90th percentile.
He's now been an
architect for 15 years.
That would get addressed
in those early grades.
Any child can benefit from
cognitive stimulation.
And when I wrote my book,
I put that as my vision
at the end of the book.
And I was convinced I would
never see that in my lifetime.
Well, we're in a school
in South Carolina.
I called my whole cohort
model-- the whole grade
2 class is doing two of
my cognitive exercises.
This is their second year,
seeing really good results.
We're just starting in a public
school just north of Sydney
in Australia.
They're taking their
whole grade 1 class.
These are just
regular grade 1 kids.
We're doing that motor
planning exercise.
If we go into the
university in Spain,
we'll just have all the students
working on that reasoning
exercise.
So the vision is
gradually happening,
and it just has huge
applications for changing
the face of education.
And that's what I'm passionate
about-- giving children
and young adults and adults
a different possibility
in their life, having many
more doors open to them
and where they can
make choice of what
door do I want to
walk through, rather
than having most doors closed
and only one possibility.
So I just want to thank you.
And I'm happy to take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have
a microphone over here
for anybody who wants
to ask questions.
Just raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
That was really interesting.
So you emphasize that
most of your work
focuses on people who have
learning disabilities.
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: Have you
tested this same kind
of techniques on patients with
Alzheimer's or other sorts
of, you know, degenerative
diseases of the brain?
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: No.
That's a really good question,
and I think a lot about that.
The answer is really
no, I haven't.
My concern is if there's a
neurodegenerative process,
I don't believe we know enough
yet to be able to reverse that.
There's certainly
research coming out
that good cognitive
stimulation maybe can stave off
the onset by a number of years.
And there's a lot of
good research looking
at people that have
dual language, which
adds cognitive load,
cognitive complexity.
And the research is suggesting
maybe it's five years later
that they show the signs,
if they're going to get
Alzheimer's.
So I think good cognitive
stimulation is positive.
I just don't think we
know enough at this point
to say that it's
going to prevent that.
AUDIENCE: Have you have you
come across any examples
where a learning disability
has manifested itself
as a learning superability
in some other context?
BARBARA
ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: I have,
and I mean, I've seen really
unevenness in profiles,
where somebody can be
exceptional in one area
and have significant
difficulty in another.
I mean, there is this
concept that I've
heard of there that there's
a gift of having a learning
disability.
I've talked to a lot of people
that have learning disability.
Nobody considers that a gift.
I mean, it doesn't
mean that maybe it
teaches you, if you can, ways
to compensate and work around.
But I myself do not
see the giftedness
in having a learning disability.
It's a struggle.
It causes suffering.
You just have to work so
much harder than everybody
else to function.
Now, I have seen
some students where
because they have a difficulty
here, they have a strength
here, and if they
rely on that strength
over and over and
over again, they're
probably creating their
own cognitive stimulation.
And they actually
improve that strength.
It doesn't change the
learning difficulty.
It improves the
strength that they have.
I mean, for me, I
think I always had
a good auditory
and visual memory,
but I supercharged them.
I mean, my way of studying,
I'd lay my books out on my bed.
As a child, I would cry from
the depths of my soul, which
I was putting my brain
in kind of a Zen state,
which I didn't know at the time.
And then I would read the
first sentence, close my eyes,
see it, read the next sentence,
close my eyes, see it.
By the end, I could look
at the first sentence.
I could close my
eyes, and I could
see 50 pages of my notebook.
I had a good ability there.
I think I enhanced that ability
through using it all the time
and over-using it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for being here.
I was just wondering, even
in your personal example,
like you go through these
training curriculums,
and you try to identify the
problem and find a solution.
After the person kind
of enhances that ability
wherever they were
weak, is there
something they have to
do to continue that?
Or is it kind of like
if you don't use it,
you lose it, kind of thing?
BARBARA ARROWSMITH YOUNG:
Interestingly what we see,
because that's a
really good question,
is there's no drop off.
I've tracked myself and other
people of over 30 years out
of the program.
And I think why--
because, I mean,
we know if we stop going to
gym, our muscles atrophy.
But I think what
happens is if we think
about that functional system,
like all these areas coming
together in a neural network,
if there's some weak areas,
they're acting as a drag
on that whole system.
Once you see you improve them,
enhance them, they come up.
And then they get
their own stimulation
by being engaged in
that neural network.
That's my theory.
It make sense to me.
Practically, what I see is
once they've achieved the gain,
there's no drop off in function.
Because I believe they're
starting to use it
in everyday functioning.
AUDIENCE: Have you noticed an
difference between children
and adults or how
neuroplasticity
changes with age?
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: Yeah,
when I first started this work,
there was all this research.
There's this beautiful
window of neuroplasticity
that starts to close at age 12.
And you know, it's kind
of all over at age 12.
So I thought I would
see a big difference
in the rate of progress in
children versus adolescents,
adults, young adults.
I haven't seen that.
It really was probably the
biggest surprise that I found.
I've seen variability in
plasticity, which makes sense.
There's individual
variability in everything.
And there's a lot of research
now looking at genetics,
looking at what goes into
different rates of plasticity.
I mean, I've got lots
of examples in my work
where two people come in.
They look very similar in the
profile, same gender, same age,
do the same amount of work.
They both make progress, but
one goes four times faster
than the other.
And there's probably just more
plasticity in that individual.
But I think about the
74-year-old retired professor
from the medical school
at University of Toronto.
She came in.
She had face blindness.
It had always bothered
her, worked on it.
She made the same
progress as a 15-year-old.
So to me, as I'm getting
older, it's really encouraging.
There's neuroplasticity
over the lifespan.
MALE SPEAKER: Big shout out
to Google for the tool kit
that you've developed.
It's really enabled us to
provide solutions for Barbara
and her team that
are very effective.
We use the App Engine.
All of our software
runs in the App Engine.
Barbara's team is
not technologists.
They're educators.
They're scientists.
They're neuroscientists.
They don't run IT shops.
The cloud has enabled
them to deliver
7/24 solutions around the world
to many different countries.
What we've worked
on with them is
capturing all that data
from those students
that we talked about earlier
and analyzing it and coming up
with individual programs for
every kid, every student,
be them adults,
whatever, and then
also tracking their progress
through those exercises
as they're working on it
and stimulating their brain,
registering the data
from year to year,
and keeping track of that
and producing reports
and report cards.
And it's your platform
that enables that.
As the next phase, we're going
to get into the classroom.
And as we get into
the classroom,
there's interactions with
the students and interactions
with the teachers, the teachers
and student interactions.
We're going to use the Android
tablet for that and the Android
operating system to connect
between the browser which
we use GWT, the GWT toolkit,
running an App Engine,
and the Android solutions
that are running on the tablet
to talk between the
teacher and the student
in the same classroom.
So big shout out, we're
using a lot of your tools,
not to mention the
Chrome browser.
And it's working out really
well for Barbara and her team.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: If Americans are more
into ketchup than Canadians,
then why do they only sell
ketchup potato chips in Canada?
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry, just kidding.
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG:
Oh really?
You don't have
ketchup potato chips?
AUDIENCE: We do not
have those here.
BARBARA ARROWSMITH
YOUNG: Oh really?
Well, no loss.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I do actually
have a real questions
that I'm curious about.
You mentioned that
you didn't learn
how to read an analog
clock until you're 26,
and similarly you
didn't understand
different sorts of abstract
relationships until that point.
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering, where
were you in life at that point?
Had you had you graduated
from college at that point?
Had you already gone to school?
Did you drop out and then
do it after you kind of
figured things out?
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG:
No, I managed to get up.
I was in graduate school.
But incredible struggle.
In my undergraduate, I learned
the routines of the security
guards in the library
because I would
spend all night in the library.
So I would know when they were
coming to do their walkabout.
I would hide out
in the washroom.
I worked seven days a week,
20 hours every single day
just to tread water.
I mean, that's what it took.
Because I wasn't
understanding conceptually.
I was having to rely on memory,
which is really brute force.
I compromised my immune system.
I have an immune
system disorder.
There's a lot of
research now looking
into the field of learning
disabilities and seeing
a connection.
It's all the stressors that
affect your endocrine system.
So it wasn't just a
learning disability.
It affected all sorts
of things in my life.
And just before I came
across the book that
was given to me-- when I
was 13, I attempted suicide.
It wasn't successful.
It was kind of that
two-edged sword--
the despair of having
a learning difficulty,
thinking I've got to
go to high school.
I could barely get
through elementary school.
How can I do this?
So that despair led me
to try to end my life.
But my learning disability
meant I didn't really
understand the instructions
of how you did that.
And I can laugh at it now.
So I wasn't successful.
But when I woke up the
next morning, as I thought
you did something.
You went to bed.
You just didn't wake up.
When I woke up the
next morning, it
was another opportunity
to attack myself,
like I just couldn't
even get that right.
But just before I
came across this work,
this time I was planning again.
And this time I would
have gotten it right,
because I knew what I had to do.
So that's why I feel like I
owe a life debt to Luria's work
because that turned
my life around.
There was no future.
Yes, I was in graduate school,
maybe I would have got through.
I'm not sure whether
I would've or not.
There was no life.
I didn't have relationships.
If I got on an elevator
in my university
and one of my
professors got on, I
was terrified that they
would ask me a question
because I wouldn't understand
what they were asking
and be able to have
a conversation.
Like, I lived in
terror all the time.
AUDIENCE: Just kind of, I
guess in all your research
and with working with so
many different clients,
any tips that you
would provide just
in general for the overall
cognitive well-being?
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: A few.
I do have slides in here,
but I didn't get to them.
One of the best
things you can do--
exercise, aerobic exercise.
There's tons of research now.
I know you've got bikes here.
You've got walking trails.
It doesn't have to
be more than go out
and walk 30 minutes a day,
a good, nice, brisk walk.
Aerobic exercise,
the rule is kind
of it's good for your heart.
It's good for your brain.
It stimulates.
It's called BDNF-- brain
derived neurotrophic factor.
And that generates neurogenesis,
creating new neurons.
Also it repair cells,
like all that damage
that happens over time.
So if you can only do
one thing, get out there
and at least five days a
week do some good exercise.
Another thing, reduce stress.
I mean, all the
research is showing now
that stress actually is
almost like an acid bath
for your brain.
I mean, short term
stress, not a problem.
It's that long term
chronic stress,
which actually creates
negative neuroplasticity.
When those dendrites
are starting to branch,
it actually eats
up the dendrites.
So anything, whether
it's meditation, again,
sometimes going for a walk.
Whatever you can do to
reduce stress in your life
is good for brain health.
Whatever you can do to
increase aerobic activity
is good for brain health.
And then the other thing is
sort of novelty and cognitive
complexity, which I
talked a little bit about.
So let's say you want
to learn something new.
What you should do is calibrate
the level of the challenge.
So let's say you
want to learn chess.
But you're not going to start
at the grandmaster level.
Because if you do, like let's
say you're functioning here
and you try to start the
activity way up here,
you aren't going to
be able to engage.
It's not going to drive
neuroplastic change.
If you make it so easy,
as your brain goes
on automatic pilot--
I mean, there's
lots of times when you want
to be on automatic pilot.
But if you're trying to
drive neuroplastic change,
automatic pilot doesn't do it.
So if you're making
something too simple,
it's not engaging the brain.
So it's kind of finding
that sweet spot,
just like in exercise.
If this is where it starts
to hurt a little bit,
make it just a little
bit more difficult.
Then do the activity,
and then you'll
find it'll little step up.
And then make it a
little more difficult.
It's calibrating the
level of complexity.
And you can do that
in any activity
that you're engaging in.
And that will be the best thing
to drive neuroplastic change.
So exercise, reduce stress,
and calibrate the level
of difficulty in your learning.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
BARBARA ARROWSMITH-YOUNG: OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]